da willkommen zur aktuellen vorlesung
für sowie der digitalität heute geht es
um die anthropologie der digitalität
kurz was zum programm der heutigen
vorlesen zunächst werde ich einen
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung gegeben
das war eine sehr spannende sitzung da
ging es um den zweiten teil der ästhetik
der digitalität zur ersten teil der
ästhetik der digitalität nach oben
rechts den winkel ein in der letzten
sitzung ging es wie gesagt und den
zweiten teil der institute der
digitalität und da ging es speziell um
computerspiele und ich möchte heute zu
beginn dieses thema noch mal ein
bisschen fortsetzen und auf das
verhältnis von ethik und ästhetik der
computerspiele eingehen was sich in der
letzten diskussion besonders als
besonders interessant herausgestellt
hatte dass nämlich die noch ein bisschen
fortsetzen mit eigenen überlegung dann
kommen wir zum eigentlichen thema der
heutigen fotos und versprechen denn es
geht um die anthropologie also die lehre
für menschen und das verhältnis zur
digitalität und abschließend werde ich
einen ausblick geben auf die nächste
sitzung in der es um die politik der
digitalität gehen soll die wir auch
schon teilweise ein bisschen behandelt
hatten jetzt aber erst zum rückblick wir
hatten ein paar leitfragen ich mache
auch nach oben rechts den link zur
letzten sitzung rein ästhetisch der
computerspiele welche philosophische
bedeutung besitzen spiele allgemein dann
im konkreten im besonderen welche
philosophische bedeutung besitzen
computerspiele
davon abhängig dann auch die frage
inwiefern sind computerspiele nur sage
jetzt mal konsum medien wie verhalten
sich computerspiele zur simulation
illusion fiktion und virtuelle realität
das ist in meinen augen die
philosophisch interessanteste frage die
man an computerspiele stellen kann damit
hängt natürlich wieder die frage so
zusammen wie fern simulieren
computerspiele realität wie verhalten
sich nutzer und computerspiele
zueinander nutzerinnen und nutzer
inwiefern sind computerspiele gar teil
einer kultur der digitalität also kann
man bei computerspielen wirklich von
einer kultur sprechen
kultur jetzt wirklich im weitesten sinne
einer lebensform wie fern sind computer
teil aller lebensformen computerspiele
auch das ist die frage und jetzt möchte
ich noch eine weitere frage hinzufügen
nämlich in wie fernsehen computerspiele
ethisch problematisch das ist jetzt der
punkt an dem ich heute weiter ansetzen
möchte zunächst noch mal ein rückblick
auf dieses zitat von friedrich schiller
der mensch spielt nur wo in voller
bedeutung des wortes mensch ist und er
ist nur da ganz mensch wo er spielt wir
sehen hier also schon eine
anthropologische aussage die auch mit
dem thema der heutigen sitzung nämlich
der anthropologie der digitalität
zusammenhängt also spiel kunden
experimentieren auch ein bisschen
unernst ausprobieren das scheint in der
natur des menschen zu leben sagt
zumindest schillern wir wollen das jetzt
auf die computerspiele beziehen im spiel
kann man sagen entwirft sich der mensch
in seiner freiheit ein spiel hat immer
regeln aber ein spiel erlaubt auch immer
gewisse freiräume und ein spiel erlaubt
es zu experimentieren das finde ich ganz
wichtig im spiel experimentiert der
mensch mit möglichkeit und wirklichkeit
man kann sagen es ist ja nur ein spiel
aber es ist auch nicht nur ein
hirngespinst spiel hat auch immer einen
gewissen realitätsgrad also hier kommen
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit ein ganz
interessantes verhältnis ein
spannungsreiches verhältnis dann kann
man sich die frage stellen stellt
computerspiele eine neue form von spiel
da meine these ist ja aber die muss man
genauer bekunden man könnte jetzt auch
argumentieren computerspiele sind nur
eine form von gewöhnlichen spielen ich
glaube dass es so nicht geht spiele sind
sehr komplex es gibt ganz verschiedene
arten von spielen es gibt ganz
verschiedene arten von computerspielen
so dass man hier sich immer auf ein
bestimmtes spiel ein bestimmtes spiel
konzentrieren muss und man kann
sicherlich sich ganz simple
computerspiele vorstellen die überhaupt
nicht anspruchsvoll sind vielleicht
tatsächlich etwas lieblose konsum medien
sind da soll jetzt nicht mein fokus
darauf liegen sind weil es ja auch eine
philosophische vorlesung ist soll mein
fokus heute auf besonders
anspruchsvollen besonders brilliert in
computerspielen wiederholen das ist das
zentrum auf welche spiele werden noch
genauer sagen worin besteht die
besonderheit von computerspielen im
gegensatz etwa zu brettspielen die
schach was ist da der unterschied sind
computerspiele nur spielen ein spiel hat
doch immer so ein bisschen etwas
ernstes einen ernsten beigeschmack sind
sie nur spieler sind sie auch etwas mehr
als das was sind sie dann genau wenn sie
mehr sind als nur spiele das sollen die
frage sein die wir auch heute noch mal
kurz thematisieren wollen ich habe jetzt
gesagt wir können die ästhetik der
digitalität im sinne von computerspielen
verstehen meine these ist diese
ambitionierten computerspiele wir hatten
da schon bei der letzten vorlesung
gebracht ich hatte da so eine kurze
evolutionstheorie evolutionsgeschichte
des computerspiels vorgestellt zeigt
dass 3d perspektive sehr zentral für
computerspiele wird immer zentraler mann
weil eben die technischen möglichkeiten
das zunehmend erlaube ein autor der
stephan günzel ging so weit sagte 3d
shooter sind das paradigma von
computerspielen also diese
zentralperspektive das sei das
eigentliche was computerspiele ausmacht
so weit würde ich nicht gehen aber es
zeigt doch dass wir hier im archiv durch
immersion eine welt einbezogen werden
können eine künstliche simulierte
fiktive welt und darin eben nicht nur
rezipienten sind seien darin auch
agieren können das scheint mir sehr
wichtig zu sein also es gibt sicherlich
computerspiele die nutzlose spielerei
sind aber man nicht alle sind das und
immer weniger computerspiele zur meine
these werden als nutzlose spieler
wahrgenommen es gibt immer er laboriert
phänomen deswegen sind computerspiele
nicht nur passiven konsum medien es
können auch computerspiele das seien
dabei es würde ihnen angesichts ihrer
differenziertheit ela probiert hat in
der heutigen entwicklung nicht mehr
gerecht werden das wäre ein
reduktionistischen zugang sie ist ein
befehl mehr das ist jetzt meine thesen
sind experimentierfelder computerspiele
auf den spielerisch also wie eben das
spiel inszeniert durch möglichkeit und
wirklichkeit erkundung die verhältnisse
von realität simulation fiktion und
illusion erprobt werden spielerisch
heißt hier kann man sich noch was
getrauen hier kann man auch etwas
riskieren ich kann man an die grenze
gehen und diese erprobung schreibt mir
ganz wichtig zu sein auch aus
anthropologischer sicher werde ich
später noch darauf zu sprechen kann
dieses verhältnis wird bestimmung
zwischen diesen verschiedenen
verhältnissen realität simulationen
fiktion illusion die erfolg nicht nur
begrifflich importeur spiel sondern
performativ also hier werden diese
verhältnisse aus agiert könnt ihr sagen
[Musik]
experimentierfreudig verhandelt das ist
dieses performative es für eine
aktivität statt und jetzt kann man sich
fragen bedeutet computer zu spielen dann
nicht am ende sogar zu philosophieren
wenn wir uns doch durch das
computerspiel mit diesen verhältnissen
von realität simulation fiktion illusion
möglichkeit und wirklichkeit diesen
ganzen metaphysischen modalitäten
auseinanderzusetzen ist dann nicht doch
computerspielen eine philosophische
tätigkeit das ist eine these die ich
heute auch ein bisschen
ins zentrum stellen möchte ich glaube so
kann man computerspielen verstehen und
dann verliert das diesen passiven
konsumierenden
aspekt filme und bilder muss man sich
jetzt zum einen vorstellen die medien
sind die veranschaulichen fiktionen
filme präsentieren millionen
dokumentationen sind ja keine lektionen
die sind ja ihr dann realität aber wenn
wir auf kinofilme gehen die jungs
typischerweise anschaut dann
veranschaulichen filme fiktion sei es
die präsentieren und die fiktion im
bewegten bild oder eben bilder im
statischen bild bilder sind natürlich
auch mehr als nur fiktion aber filme
haben schon stark fiktiven charakter
texte hingegen wenn es nicht romane
anschauen die initiieren nur fiktionen
sie appellieren aber zugleich an unsere
kreative menschliche fantasie also
dasjenige was der film macht indem er
uns das bild das bewegte bild
präsentiert das macht der text nicht der
beschreibt der stellte aber vor unserem
geistigen auge müssen wir dann fantasie
dieses erzählte zum leben also vor augen
entstehen lassen wir müssen mehr selbst
aktiv werden und das ganze kann man
diese weiter spinnt nämlich wenn wir auf
computerspiele eingehen computerspiele
veranschaulichen und appellieren
zugleich unsere phantasie sie haben
einerseits etwas was starke narrativen
charakter hat das war die debatte sind
computerspiele jetzt mehr aktionen also
erzählungen oder sind sie letztendlich
nur
spiele das waren die marathon logo und
die neurologen die sich da so ein
bisschen streiten ich glaube es sind von
beiden aspekten dinge zu finden wir
haben einerseits in computerspielen
etwas vorgegeben eine computerspiel welt
das ist vielleicht die beiden
kinofilm zum fall zugleich sind wir aber
nicht nur passiv diese diesem bild
ausgesetzt und wir werden selbst aktiv
und könnt dann wieder unsere fantasie
aktivieren als es hat eine ganz
besondere stellung des computerspiels zu
anderen medien unterhaltungsmedien jetzt
mal oberflächlich gesagt wie filmen
bildern oder auch texten romano zum
beispiel
computerspiele sind deswegen
selbstbestimmte simulationen von
fiktionen das wäre mein definitions
versucht fiktionen deswegen weil in
allermeisten fällen und computerspiele
wie auch romane von welten handeln die
es so nicht gibt gibt es immer momente
die biologisch sind fiktiv sind sind
aber simulationen von fiktionen weil wir
nur so tun als ob die jetzt wirklich
würden es ist ja nicht die realität
diversen computerspielen erleben sind
immer noch sieben simulationen aber sind
selbstbestimmte simulation weil ich eben
nicht wie im film dem fiktiven passiv
ausgesetzt natürlich reflektiere ich
auch auf das medium film ich mache mir
meine gedanken dazu ich habe emotionen
aber das was fiktives wird mir
präsentiert im computerspiel wird es mir
einerseits präsentiert andererseits kann
ich selbst an der fiktion mitarbeiten
einen eigenen weg ein schlag und das
macht computerspiele häufig auch so
spannend dass da eine form von
selbstbestimmung
auch integriert ist wie wir sie bei
filmen und auch bei text nicht finden
weil ich meine geschichte im
computerspiel selbst weiterentwickeln
kann im buch im film wird sie mir
vorgegeben gewissermaßen darum dass das
ist so ein punkt was in meinen augen das
computerspiel auszeichnet weil eben der
autonome aspekte selbstbestimmte aspekt
mit blick auf die fiktion die erzählung
stark im zentrum steht und diese
autonome aus bekond jedem durch das
spielerische moment ins spiel wie eben
china sagt er hat was mit freiheit und
autonomie und selbstbestimmung zu tun
computerspiele sind insofern bestand an
einer kultur der digitalität alt sind
ihnen das problem der virtuellen
realität spielerisch verhandelt wird und
spielerisch heißt eben immer
experimentell und auch mit freiheit
verbunden und selbstbestimmung im rahmen
einer kultur der digitalität können
computerspiele sehr wohl zu virtuellen
realitäten werden sodass das simulator
und fiktiver charakter in den
hintergrund ich bin aber dafür nicht so
schnell mit blick auf computerspiele von
virtueller realität zu sprechen einfach
deswegen weil wir es den allermeisten
fällen mit simulationen zu tun und wir
sollten diese begriffe nicht verwischen
ich komme gleich noch genauer drauf
warum ist keine virtuelle realität ist
realität wenn es um das verhältnis von
ethik und ästhetik geht dennoch kommen
virtuelle realität zustande wenn etwa in
form von multiplayer spielen
spielerinnen und spieler gegeneinander
antreten und dann tatsächlich nicht nur
simulieren sondern wirklich interagieren
auch mit einem bestimmten ziel als
objektivierbar ist computerspiele könnte
man auch sagen sind dynamische
kunstwerke dynamisch deswegen bei die
rezipienten selbst zu produzenten werden
sie bekommen einerseits was vorgegeben
haben aber eben andererseits auch eine
kreative gestaltungskraft künstliche
intelligenz lässt zum beispiel gesagt
wird immer mehr teile von
computerspielen er gibt es eben die das
phänomen dass künstliche intelligenz
lernt wie sich die nutzerinnen oder der
computerspieler verhält und danach sich
ausrichtet also die daten des nutzers
des spielers der spielerinnen werden
selbst zu einer basis für
mustererkennung einer der spieler die
spielerin als muster
und die künstliche intelligenz
orientiert sich daran dass dynamisiert
natürlich das verhältnis von computer
spielerin und künstliche intelligenz
extrem auch ein extremer zukunftsbereich
und computerspielen dass es noch ein
weiterer punkt den wir hinzufügen möchte
werden verschiedene rollen personale
identität durch avatar gegeben so
spielerisch verhandelt also in denen wir
hier eine fiktive gestalt annehmen
können die wir selbst bestimmen können
wir mit unserer identität auch spielen
und das macht gerade so multiplayer
spiele wie world of warcraft so
fasziniert weil wir auf anonym oder
pseudonym darin interagieren können ja
jetzt möchte ich auf dieses thema noch
mal zu sprechen können was das
verhältnis von ethik und ästhetik des
computerspiels trifft das auch ein thema
was immer wichtiger wird ich hatten der
letzten sitzung erzählt viele dieser
computerspiele wurden zu beginn
indiziert zb wolfenstein 3d und quake
wenn im computerspielen die verhältnisse
von realität virtualität simulation
fiktion und illusion spielerisch
verhandelt werden dann stellt sich die
frage nach dem verhältnis von ethik und
ästhetik wie verein handelt es sich bei
simon beim simulierten töten zum
beispiel von simuliert personen um eine
moralisch verwerfliche rang es ist ja
dass tatsächlich eine handlung ich töte
im computerspiel eine simulierte person
das kommt durchaus vor zum beispiel
wolfenstein 3d inwiefern ist das
simulierte töten von simulierten
personen durch die freiheit der kunst
gerechtfertigt und gedeckt das ist auch
nicht fragen die man sich hier stellen
kann keiner sagen ist doch nur ein spiel
das hat auch mit der wirklichkeit gar
nichts zu tun denn computerspiele mehr
sind als nur ästhetische familie dann
wird allerdings auch das simulierte
töten von simulierten personen ethisch
problematisch nach computerspiele haben
immer einen bezug auf die realität weil
sie ja auch simulieren sind ja nicht nur
fiktiv
sie haben immer einen gewissen
realitätsgehalt eben durch die
simulation
abgedeckt ist und durch diesen
simulatoren und wirklichkeit charakter
wirklichkeit bezug müssen auch ethische
reflexionen stattfinden als eine bloß
ästhetische betrachtungsweise des
computerspiels nehmen mein augenzeugen
jetzt kann man sich eben frage wie
verhält es sich beim simulierten töten
von virtuellen mit spielern wie sieht es
da aus na also wenn man einen computer
spielt gegen nicht nur gegen künstliche
intelligenz antritt sondern gegen andere
mitspielerin mitspieler es gibt viele
solcher spiele hier stellt sich
natürlich immer die frage in welchem
kontext dieses töten stattfindet wird es
gerahmt durch eine fiktion wird es als
spieler sichtlich oder steht der
simulator charakter stark im zentrum
davon muss man diese ethische bewertung
unbedingt abhängig machen je mehr als
simulant even charakter hat das
theoretisch problematischer kann es
werden auch wenn es immer noch eine
simulation ist im gegen in fiktiven und
illusionen tritt diese ethische aspekt
immer weniger ins zentrum da tritt mir
der ästhetische aspekt im vordergrund
das wären so meine versuche dieses thema
zu
kategorisieren und jetzt geht es um die
leidvollen der heutigen vorlesen welche
anthropologischen implikationen gehen
mit dem phänomen der digitalität einher
wie verhalten sich anthropologie und
virtuelle realität zueinander wie
verhalten sich digitalität und
transformer nissans zueinander das
scheint mir auch eine besonders zentrale
frage zu sein weil die transnistrische
bewegung sehr viel zulauf bekommen hat
weil sich die technologie sehr positiv
weiterentwickelt haben das sind die
fragen das möchte ich erstmal auf den
tanz humanismus eingehen was darunter zu
verstehen gibt es ein
wegbereiter einen prominenten vertreter
des rallye kurzweil gewonnen also 48 ich
habe hier eine kurze information aus
wikipedia nach seinem studium erfand er
die kurzwahl reding erschien die
sehbehinderten erstmals den zugang
sondern malen texten ermöglichte dem ist
die texte in akustische signale
umwandelt und somit vorlas kurzweile
erfindung gilt bis heute als größter
meister zur gesellschaftlichen
integration sehbehinderte nach dieser
erfindung der blindenschrift gegründete
983 auch noch unternehmen kurzweil news
existenz vielleicht kennt der eine oder
die andere von ihm diese sind es die
bahnstadt damals in der lage fröhliche
klänge in besonders gute qualität zu
erzeugen also hier ging es auch um das
erzeugen von simulationen vielleicht
auch von virtuellen realitäten als es
handelt sich bei ray kurzweil um 1 gegen
durchaus hoch begnadeten techniker
ingenieur erfinder die frage ist ist er
auch ist auch seine theorie der
singularität um die wir um die wir uns
heute befassen ist die ebenso überzeugen
wie seine technischen erfindungen da
habe ich ein paar zweifel oder ein paar
punkte die ich kritisch anmerken möchte
er gründete im jahr 2008 auch die
singularity
universitäten und kürzt 1 quelle
wikipedia
wir müssen uns jetzt auf den begriff der
singularität konzentrieren denn wie ray
kurzweil stranz humanismus verstehen
wollen er sagt ihr zu der frage was
singularität ist in the future periods
pace of technological change the beast
rapid ist in pécs der termin war für
diverse transfers
geht um eine transformation die das
ganze menschliche leben betrifft man
spricht auch häufig von einer disruption
diese begriffe transformation
dysfunktion auch das exponentielle die
sind hier ganz wichtig für transparenz
des security will representation auf dem
workshop
lautschrift winkel in existenznot
technology consulting water is too human
body transcends albert kruse
station post security beträgt human
machine und bitte den physiker und
virtual reality
ganz wichtig hier es geht um eine
verbindung von biologie und technologie
an die einheit von evolutionstechnisch
evolution biologische art und evolution
technologischer art die wird dadurch
hergestellt die konvergieren
gewissermaßen diese beiden revolutionen
und sie konnten agieren dadurch dass die
exponentiell verlaufen zumindest die
technologische entwicklung und es gibt
dann am ende sagte er gar keinen
unterschied mehr zwischen mensch und
maschine und zwischen physischer und
virtueller realität ja das ist eine
spannende durch eine visionäre
perspektive die uns auf zeigt in seinem
buch der singularity ist mehr als die
these dass diese figur zustand in dem
zwischen menschen maschinen immer
weniger differenz sein wird dass die
eben nahe ist die singularität hier sind
titel dieses buches the humans trends
and biology also transzendent ist ein
weiterer begriff neben tanz formation
disruption und auch neben den begriff
des exponentiellen und wo wir beim
begriff des exponentiellen sind möchte
man die grafe geben auf der x-achse die
bis ins jahr 2100 reicht sehen wir die
zeit und auf der y-achse die
kalkulationen pro sekunde pro 1 dollar
es geht um eine ökonomische
technologische größe die auf der y-achse
abgetragen wird und er sagt jetzt diese
kurve die werden hier über die zeit weg
verfolgen kann die hat eine
exponentielle form die ist nichtlinear
dass es geradezu gerade weil er geht
nimmt mit zunehmendem alter der zeit zu
und zwar extremen steigung und hier
sagte eben die das management das
menschliche gehirn das wäre so im jahr
2025 vielleicht ungefähr erreicht durch
technologie
hingegen im jahr
2060 alle eben menschliche gehirne
zusammen durch die technologische
entwicklung
muss man mit vorsicht geniessen weil wir
ja erst hier sind also hier 2020 was
hätte man da ja und gefährden maus
gehirn ich bin jetzt kein
naturwissenschaftler müsste man sich
untersuchen ob man tatsächlich schon
soweit ist er hatte diese these schon
vor einigen jahren geäußert
das ist die security university
axxelerate change also beschleunigt er
wandelt das hat wieder was mit diesen
exponentiellen wachstum zu tun
experimente und technologies changes
fundament von der mensch als auf der
site des walking business and government
hier wieder disruption
ja das ist so diese these er hat noch
ein weiteres buch geschrieben das die
age of spirit olma sheens agent computer
exceet jungen intelligence hier geht es
um das verhältnis von künstlicher
intelligenz und singularität ich will
mal hier ein paar zitate noch lesen
xtreme verbier mortality bei während das
zentrum wird s ens der dlv nicht
wirklich you take advantage of the
twentieth century screening technology
japan genau alternatives teilt ohne
lange witthaut wenn die hardware crash
der transit von mini auf
vorbild der haut weltweit tätig bevor
geht des integrated jedes land hat die
pendler physical selbst etwas back up
with that caught up on a stick er ist
die cross privat instanz cells and
computational technology aber identität
ebay sind aber egal wie gemein feuer
über die software nordhorn also es geht
hier ganz stark auch um die frage nach
sterblichkeit nach endlichkeit und er
behauptet jetzt die these dass ist zum
ende des einst reichsten jahrhunderts
und personale identität an der unsere
endlichkeit ein sterblichkeit hängt das
die immer mehr in software charakter
haben wird und sich von der hardware
also uns von physischen körper lösen
wird die software und hardware als eine
dieser maßnahme vergeistigung eine
software easy rung unserer identität die
eben dadurch los lösbar ist von unserem
sterblichen körper es geht also um die
frage nach der umständlichkeit es
software mortality will no longer be die
pendler aus der computer
wirklich still be heard the police bei
die essens auf ihre identität switch to
the parents of justice cd mit
jamie change personal computers die
trends for the least once we want you to
want from me fire katy perry a decade of
the latest even more coverage and also
wenn sie an neuen computer sich kaufen
müssen sie erst mal die daten sichern
die daten wieder drauf laden sei es
durch die clowns durch die festplatte
und so argumentiert er geht es auch mit
unserer personale identität die ist
unabhängig von der haut also vom
computer es geht um die software so
lange wir die software kontinuierlich
auf neue hardware laden könnt existieren
wir weiter und somit würde sich unsere
existenz eben extrem verlängern
vielleicht sogar wissens unsterblich das
ist hier eine gewisse perspektive die
ein tanz tendenz auch beschreiben also
eine ganz starke
normativ hoch interessante perspektive
der mensch als software und jetzt müssen
wir uns ein bisschen genauer mit der
anthologie des computers
auseinandersetzen weil auch da hat ray
kurzweil das sozusagen auf calls
computers wollte diskret objects
dvd player bietet in our brains and
environment aber denn die die and
survival alte mitglied bekommen
independent oft haben wir zwei
alternativen bier madoffs efficiently
cache friedland backups für kerle sabbat
ist will have to load und backup kopien
bedingte bauriesen passt entscheiden ist
mir hier dieser erste und zweite satz
computer in der zukunft sind immer mehr
eingebettet in unsere körperliche natur
oder auch unsere nun zum kontext sind
nicht mehr objekte die uns irgendwie
gegenüberstehen sind sie werden
gewissermaßen zu winter objektiven ich
habe den begriff auch schon eingeführt
nach oben rechts den link kleinste thema
inter objektivität dass ich diesen
gedanken scheint er hier aufzugreifen
allerdings eben auf eine sehr spezielle
art wendet um die identifizierung von
menschliche identität und software geht
computer storage autos extensions auf
einen cent ab henning minds machines ibm
integriert tv sensation und essentials
bürger machines abgetrennte fünf zentren
dem es in mein auch gar nicht zu
widersprechen sie sind und werden immer
mehr teil unserer lebenswelt die frage
ist ob damit einhergeht dass wir nur
noch soft wert sein werden das möchte
ich stark bestreiten das scheint mir ein
schluss zu sein alter nicht folgt und
jetzt komme ich ein bisschen allgemeiner
auf den transfer eines entsprechenden
ray kurzweil ist eben eine ein vertreter
des tanks humanismus spezielle
ausprägung das ist dieses symbol des
transformers muss und ich habe mich hier
wieder auf die ganz schlau gemacht
ransmann ismus von lateinisch trans
jenseits über hinaus und formlos
menschlich ist eine philosophische
denkrichtung die grenzen menschlicher
möglichkeiten sei es intellektuell
physisch oder psychisch durch den
einsatz technologischer verfahren
erweitert die interessen und werte der
menschheit werden als verpflichtungen
zum fortschritt angesehen ich möchte
noch hinzufügen es geht hier auch um die
moralischen fortschritt also trans mann
ist im und pensionisten argumentieren
häufig auch das endlich nur technisch
und intellektuell besser wird es eben
auch moralisch und im zoo im sinne steht
diese transnistrische tradition in der
tradition der aufklärung und auch im
metalltür eines perfektionismus eines
moralischen der fortschritt ist immer
auch ein moralischer fortschritt das
scheint hier auch ganz häufig mit einher
zu gehen ja da hat jetzt julian
nida-rümelin mit seinem buch digitale
humanismus eine wie ich finde sehr
treffende kritik am trans finalist muss
formuliert er schreibt wir entwickeln in
diesem buch weg und züge eines digitalen
organismus als alternative zu dem was
man etwas vereinfachend als silicon
valley youtube bezeichnen kann diese
hängt mit der uramerikanischen
puritanisch geprägten erlösung hoffnung
zusammen eine welt der rhein und
gerechten zu schaffen die schmutz und
sünde hinter sich gelassen hat also hier
wieder diese moralische fortschritt so
ein paar zitate
ähnlich dem prädikat schon winthrop der
in seiner berühmten drehte city april
statt auf einem möglichen jahres 16 03
sich den puritanischen siedlern mut und
hoffnung machen wollte dem er sie auf
ihre sonderstellung und die
herausragende bedeutung der besiedlung
für den rest der welt hin wie ist wir
könnten viele software ingenieure aus
silicon valley ihre auserwähltheit und
die einzigartigkeit ihres arbeitsplatzes
an den bedingungen stehen die für den
rest der menschheit wichtig sind die
pilze engineers
of
humans problems blieb
die menschen deswegen wieder aufgebaut
haben waren ingenieure sie kannten sich
mit business ausgelernten fiel vor allem
aber glauben sie fest dass sie wenn sie
nur hart mit anderen kreativen menschen
arbeiten die meisten probleme der
menschen lösen werden so ein spruch
könnte etwa von elon musk stand silicon
valley um die arbeit an ki wird damit
metaphysisch aufgeladen sie bedeutet
nicht nur big business sie ist auch eine
glaubensfrage zu weit julian
nida-rümelin noch ein zitat die
zentralen werte dieses glaubens sind
transparenz und berechenbarkeit
ökonomische erfolg und mit zehn
ethisches engagement zeiten der
digitalisierung bringe sie perfekt
konstruierte gegenüber vor software
identitäten deren konstruktion jeden
fehler ausschließt und die uns als
partner in ein technologisches utopia
führen der schlüsselbegriff ist dabei
der der künstliche intelligenz
aufgeladen mit unausgesprochenen mit der
musik und technologie eine sich selbst
verbessern der hyper rationale zunehmend
beseelte entität deren schöpfer
allerdings mit gott oder götter sind
sondern software ingenieure aus silicon
valley die sich selbst nicht lediglich
als teil in einer industrie verstehen
sind einen übergreifenden geistigen
bewegung geriet hoffmann familie zurück
in berlin ist am 1 motto location
silicon valley als inbegriff des
transformers massa
sehr spannende kritik ein letzte tat von
julian nida-rümelin die silicon valley
ideologie nimmt humanistischen pulse als
ausgangspunkt um sie dann nicht zum
ersten mal eine kulturgeschichte
menschheit zu antikommunistischen
utopien zu transformieren sie beginnt
bei der verbesserung des humanen und
endet in seiner finalen überwindung sie
will das menschliche leben auf dem
planeten verbessern und stellt die
bedingung von humanität in frage sie
überführt den humanismus zu trans mannis
muss und zur technik zwischen utopie in
der das menschliche auf der strecke
bleiben dem stellt sich der digitale
humanismus als eine ethik für das
zeitalter der künstlichen intelligenz
entgegen so versteht juni darin sein
buch ja er kritisiert also sehr stark
diese bewegung des salafismus sondern
müssen uns fragen wie fern trifft diese
kritik zu finden ist sie auch vielleicht
etwas problematisch ihrerseits jetzt
gehen wir mal auf die probleme des
konsumismus kurz zusammenfassen ein der
trans man ismus
extrapoliert auf künftige entwicklungen
durch analogien und prognose hat also
das ganz stark
weiterführendes weiterdenken ist aber
dass in sehr bestimmte form der trans
humanismus orientiert sich an der
biologischen evolutionstheorie und
erweitert diese durch eine
technologische evolution story in der
technik und mensch immer mehr
konvergieren das war das was will
kurzweil sagte dass diese trennung
zwischen mensch und immer weniger
bestehen würde und julian nida-rümelin
kritisiert dass er meint das passt
gerade antikommunistisch sei wenn man
diese trennung zwischen mensch und
maschine mehr auf hebt das unternehmen
besitzt bestimmt spekulativ flüge und er
besitzt auch ideologische züge das ist
glaube ich und bestritten die domain
spricht von der silicon valley ideologie
und man kann auch sagen der kommunismus
ist perfektionistisch und techno
optimistisch inwiefern das ein problem
ist na ja er sieht eben nicht so sehr
die schatten zahlen die eben auch die
technologisierung einhergehen jede
technik ist ja als solche nicht nur
positiv das hängt immer davon ab wie wir
sie gebraucht und diese gebrauchte
technologie wird im transit man es muss
völlig ausgeblendet weil dieser gebrauch
für die technologie aus dieser sicht gar
nicht notwendig ist weil die technologie
sich selbst gebraucht also sich selbst
gewissermaßen recht fährt und gar
niemand gar keine anderen instanz bedarf
um sie einzusetzen die technologie ist
sollten als solche im recht und das
scheint mir etwas zu optimistisch zu
sein auch mit blick auf mögliche
negative entwicklung durchaus hoch
problematisch wie hier noch einen
weiteren punkt der tradition ist muss
versteht sich als bewegung der
aufklärung das ist sicherlich ganz
wichtig in einer kontinuität das sehen
aber es ist eine übertriebene aufklärung
die man durchaus kritisieren kann die
eben die schatten zeit nicht
berücksichtigt jede aufklärung hat man
auch eine aufklärungs tendenz die sich
den problematischen seiten zu finden und
nicht nur perfektionistisch operiert
insofern ist er eine verkürzte form
verkauft leerung scheint mehr und man
muss sich natürlich auch eine aufklärung
der digitalität widmen aufklärung im
digitalzeitalter das machen wir der
nächsten sitzungen müssen die politik
die kita lied geht aber diese kritische
gesichtspunkt scheint mehr im transit
ismus viel zu kurz zu kommen
jetzt möchte ich noch ein bisschen
allgemeiner auf dieses verhältnis von
anthropologie und digitalität eingehen
was im zentrum der heutigen vorlesungen
stehen soll
anthropologie und digitalität stehen
einem engen verhältnis zueinander
welches nicht durch die opposition
mensch technik oder mensch maschine
charakterisiert ist hier würde ich also
durchaus ray kurzweil etwas folgen und
zu sagen technik und mensch sollte nicht
zu sehr an gegensatz gebracht werden sie
sollten aber auch nicht so sehr
korrigieren und fusioniert werden dass
wir ganz offen dieser differenz absehen
können aber geht der trans man ismus
zweit aber ich glaube wir müssen sonder
mit uns ein pendeln also die menschen
der mensch maschine mensch technik
relation sollte etwas enger gefasst
werden nicht mehr nur sehr
objektives tisch ich habe das den
begriff der inter objektivität dafür ins
spiel gebracht wenn digitalität durch
den betrieb der virtuellen realität
bestimmt ist und entscheiden eben ein
schlüsselbegriff dafür zu sein nach oben
rechts den link zur sitzung über
virtuelle realität hinein in das der
fall ist dann muss auch die
anthropologie vom begriff der
digitalität her verstanden werde also
ich glaube wir können anthropologie
ihren digitalität durch den begriff der
virtuellen realität ein sehr enges
verhältnis bringen was eben diese brücke
zwischen mensch und technik oder mensch
verschieden und überwinden hilft ohne
dass wir gleich trans mann ist in trans
minister werden müssen virtuelle
realität wird als eine dimension und
existenz weise des menschen nicht bar
die in seiner freiheit besteht also mit
geht es darum zu zeigen digitalität und
mensch anthropologie stehen sie nicht
entgegen wie eine technik mensch
maschine sondern digitalität ist eine
form von
anthropologie warum weil sie auf die
virtuelle realität verweist und
virtuelle realität ist in meinen augen
immer eine dimension des menschen warum
die freiheit durch die virtuelle
realität aber auch durch das spiel das
computerspiel ist immer eine kreative
freiheit die es erlaubt vorhandene und
bekannte dinge auf eine andere weise neu
zu realisieren also hier ist wieder der
begriff des virtuellen also von dateien
wird als tugend tüchtigkeit kraft ganz
wichtig der mensch als solcher in dieser
anthologie hat immer schon die tendenz
bekanntes auf neue weise zu realisieren
das liegt in seiner freiheit insofern
ist der virtuelle realität nichts den
menschen fremd ist was es erst seit der
digitalisierung gibt nein es ist eine
kunst tendenz des menschen die virtuelle
realität und insofern ist auch die
digitalisierung
digitalität anschließbar an diese
tendenz der virtuellen realität also ist
gar nichts menschen fremd ist sondern
eigentlich etwas typisch menschlich ins
digitale das wäre meine thesen und damit
haben da eben dann diese mensch technik
differenz überwunden ohne gleich so weit
gehen zu müssen und menschen technik
wirklich verschwinden zu lassen was die
begriffe aufheben wird das würde in
meiner zeit gehen ja das waren sie meine
thesen zum verhältnis von anthropologie
und digitalität also kurz
zusammengefasst mensch und technik
digitale technik können dann eine
lebensweltliche einheit gebracht werden
wenn wir sie über den begriff der
virtuellen realität verstehen die ihnen
grundsätzlich ein dimension des menschen
ist insofern ist digitalität nur eine
ausprägung menschlicher freiheit das
wäre meine these jetzt möchte ich ein
ausblick auf die nächste sitzung geben
wird februar da geht es um die politik
der digitalität ich war schon kurz
darauf zu sprechen gegangen gekommen in
einem der vergangenen sitzungen gibt es
einen menschen recht auf internet-zugang
das hatte ich ja schon so ein bisschen
formuliert julian nida-rümelin
argumentiert übrigens auch dass wir auf
den werde ich auch noch mal eingehen
wenn man das weiterdenken sollte es eine
globale internet regierung geben das
internet ist ja nichts lokales oder auch
nationales sind müssen bestreitet ja
alle nationalen grenzen da liegt es auf
der hand von einer internet regierung zu
sprechen oder ist das internet politisch
gewissermaßen anarchistisch das ist auch
eine möglichkeit zu sagen nein es soll
eben nicht regiert werden das internet
als handlungsraum das würde es nie
schränken das wäre der tendenz des
internets geradezu wieder wir müssen
eine form von selbstorganisation
spontaner selbstorganisation zu grunde
legen die nicht von oben und von unten
entwickelt werden muss dass es auch eine
legitime these und daneben die
allerwichtigste frage die wir uns in
dieser sitzung stehen wollen auch noch
im dress des semesters benötigen wir
eine digitale aufklärung und falls ja
wie sieht diese digitale aufklärung aus
das ist die frage die wir uns im
nächsten sitzung stellen wollen ich
bedanke mich vielmals für die
aufmerksamkeit und bin gespannt auf die
diskussion